[Música]
vamos a ver ahora el desempeño de los
mercados en la jornada de hoy y las
noticias relacionadas con la economía
está conmigo en el estudio Jorge Hurtado
Jorge muy buenas noches comenzamos
hablando de esas previsiones de pérdidas
económicas que puede llegar a tener
Estados Unidos a raíz del paso del
huracán sobre todo por el estado de la
Florida Santiago y es que la firma en
Search dice que el huracán Ian podría
dejar en pérdidas entre 30.000 y 60.000
millones de dólares eso en daños y
pérdidas económicas de cumplirse estos
cálculos el huracán podría ser el octavo
más costoso en la historia de Estados
Unidos hasta hoy había 2,6 millones de
clientes de electricidad en Florida
oscuras de acuerdo con el sitio de
monitoreo de energía eléctrica Power
artech artemis una empresa de análisis
de bonos de catástrofes y valores
vinculados a los seguros afirma que el
sector de los seguros se enfrentaría a
una pérdida de 20 mil millones de
dólares el gobernador de la Florida
declaró 9 condados como zona de desastre
la permitiría que está esto las personas
en estos condados acceden ayudas de
parte de la agencia Federal del manejo
de emergencias unos 20.000 cruceros
también están atrapados en el mar
Durante los próximos dos días ya que
tres de los principales puertos de
Florida estarán cerrados por este
huracán hablemos ahora del senado
también de Estados Unidos porque aprobó
un proyecto de ley de gasto a corto
plazo que le permitiría evitar el cierre
del gobierno de qué se trata Bueno este
proyecto tiene una novedad atrae ayuda
económica y militar para Ucrania el
proyecto de ley financia al Gobierno
Federal hasta el 16 de diciembre y da a
los legisladores más tiempos para
acordar una legislación que establezca
los niveles de gasto para el año fiscal
2023 ahora pasa la cámara de
representantes para su consideración
pero esta aprobación solamente aplaza
durante unos meses las negociaciones
después de las elecciones de mitad de
mandato para aprobar un enorme paquete
de financiación del gobierno ahí se
tendrán que resolver diferencias sobre
el gasto en temas como el aborto la
seguridad fronteriza y el cambio
climático el proyecto contempla 12 mil
millones de dólares que se destinarán a
ayuda a Ucrania crucemos el Atlántico
Vamos hasta Europa hablemos de esa
crisis energética en el viejo continente
Alemania va a invertir 200 mil millones
de euros en el tope de los precios
energéticos de qué se trata esta
estrategia bueno así lo anunció el
canciller Alemán o las choles tras un
acuerdo de la coalición de gobierno de
socialdemócrata verdes y liberales
Alemania que ha defendido en gran medida
de las importaciones de combustibles
fósiles de Rusia para satisfacer sus
necesidades energéticas se ha visto
ahora sometida a un enorme presión a
medida que los suministros de Moscú van
disminuyendo escuchemos que decía el
canciller
sin embargo Esto hace que los precios
sean elevados lo que hace que muchos
ciudadanos y también muchas empresas de
nuestro país se enfrenten a un gran reto
que no se puede superar fácilmente los
precios deben bajar Esta es nuestra
firme convicción y el Gobierno Federal
hará todo lo posible para conseguirlo
pasemos ahora temas de América Latina en
México el Banco Central decidió subir
nuevamente los tipos de interés una
decisión similar tomaron también en
Colombia así es el banco mexicano
decidió subir el interés de referencia
el 75 puntos básicos como parte de sus
esfuerzos para hacer frente a los altos
niveles de inflación con la nueva subida
de la tasa de interés objetivo aumentó
hasta un nuevo máximo de
9,25%. El incremento estaba dentro las
expectativas del mercado tras revelarse
la semana pasada que la inflación
general subió en la segunda quincena de
septiembre hasta el 8,76% anual su mayor
nivel desde el año 2000 van 5 como
también se conoce el Banco Central prevé
que la inflación general promedie un
8,6% anual en el último trimestre de
2022 tras la expectativa anterior que
tenían del 8,1% aumenta digamos la
presión y las expectativas sobre la
subida de los precios
metaplataformance que es la propietaria
de las redes sociales de Facebook y de
Instagram dijo que esta empresa va a
frenar la contratación no pintan bien
las cosas por allí bueno según bloomber
también la empresa entra en un proceso
de reestructuración en un esfuerzo por
reducir los costos y cambiar algunas
prioridades el anuncio estuvo a cargo de
Mark Zuckerberg el director ejecutivo de
meta según él la empresa reducirá los
presupuestos de múltiples equipos de
trabajo y estos deberán resolver como
operar aún cuando el número de personal
se vea reducido y trabajar para
gestionar a las personas que no estén
teniendo éxito Según dijo antes me te
había dicho que tenía planteado reducir
la contratación para algunos puestos
gerenciales meta no es la única ya
varias empresas tecnológicas se han
visto obligadas a recortar sus
plantillas en los últimos meses esto
porque los anunciantes recortan su gasto
para prepararse ante una posible
recesión económica a propósito de la
subida de los tipos de interés en todo
el mundo y hablemos ahora de la cifra
del día para el cierre volvemos a México
1,2 millones de empresas fueron Víctimas
de delitos en 2021 en México esto según
la encuesta Nacional de victimización de
empresas de 2021 el número de empresas
afectadas por la delincuencia equivale
al 24,6% del total de unidades
económicas en ese país la inseguridad
costó a las empresas mexicanas un total
de 6000 millones de dólares Aunque la
cifra representa menos de la mitad de
las empresas que perdieron dinero debido
a la delincuencia él en el año 2019
Muchas gracias Jorge por esta
actualización a continuación en directo
América damos inicio a el debate